hello there did you really believe that
attention is all you need
according to the papers of the last
weeks not anymore
in today's video we showcase the ethnet
paper replacing the self-attention
invert
with fourier transforms four year one
miss coffee bean did you know it all
along that self-attention is doomed
then why didn't you tell me is it
because i left you in the coffee roaster
for such a long time
here we go the f-net proposed in this
paper
does one modification to the transformer
architecture
but this one thing has quite the impact
for a bit of a context here the
transformer
composed of self-attention followed by
fully connected layers
and not to forget about the residual
connections and
layer normalization had been proven to
be extremely successful
on multiple data modalities it started
with text
became mainstream on both image and text
then on image only
i watched miss coffee beans videos for
all of this then it moved on to speech
and even further than that
but powerful as it is the transformer
has
a problem the self-attention mechanism
scales quadratically in time and memory
with increasing
sequence length in other words there is
a limit to what the length of your text
might be
for images the size or resolution also
determines the sequence length
and with usual transformers you can
reach the sequence length limit
quite fast so far methods to reduce this
quadratically scaling attention to a
linearly
scaling operation have left the concept
of
attention untouched methods like
linformer performer and others have
cleverly approximated self-attention
matrices
sped up computations and enabled much
longer sequences
but the concept of attention stayed
mostly
as it was well so far because now
heretic papers are coming out and rebel
against attention no it's not a tension
that we need anymore miss coffee bean is
machine learning now a teenager
and doesn't want attention anymore
because this is exactly what fnet also
does it replaces the self-attention
layers through
40 transforms but the most important
question here is
how dare the authors make such a move
and
not call their paper fourier is all you
need
the audacity of these authors is
unbelievable sarcasm
okay so let's see how this replacement
of attention
works and what it brings the ethnic
authors take the classical transformer
block and modify it by replacing the
self-attention layer containing
learnable parameters with an
unparameterized
thus not a learned transformation
being the fourier transform so before
for each token self-attention layers
we're learning to
compute important scores for the token
given all other tokens so to emphasize
the computation of the importance is
learned from data
is task specific and the new
representation for each token was the
sum of all tokens
weighted by their importance to the
original token
now with the fourier transform the new
representation for a token is not
learned but
it is a predefined mixing scheme of
tokens
this makes this whole thing faster
because this layer doesn't perform any
gradient updates but
is also unchanged from task to task
or one training scenario to another the
mixing scheme of the tokens is following
the rules of the 40 transformation
now what exactly is this this is where
the math
gets a little complicated but it does
not need to scare you
here it is just written that each token
is multiplied by sines and cosines
because this e to the power of something
we can write as a superposition of sines
and cosines hand
wavy like this so for example the first
token is a weighted sum of all other
tokens but
here the weights are modulated by sines
and cosines but
because we are at the first token where
k
equals zero the frequency of the sines
of cosines
hidden in this exponential is zero
so the first token is just the sum of
all other tokens for
the second token the modulation is more
interesting by superimposing waves that
increase in frequency as we add more
tokens
for the third token the frequency of
each wave we add increases even more
like this to put it as an analogy the
new representation of each token
is like a cake where the base
frequency is still the first token then
the second token adds
some detail and becomes the cream on the
cake
then the third token becomes the even
more detailed icing
the fourth token is the super detailed
nuts and so on
and then the whole cake is the new token
representation
because we take the summation of all of
this and to be fair
all of this has real and complex
components but forget about it because
after all the operations are computed
the authors delete the imaginary
component
anyway the important messages here are
firstly
the fourier transform applied to tokens
mixes the tokens among
themselves it's kind of similar to what
self-attention does but self-attention
learned the weights by which these
things need to be mixed
also the same thing is done to the
hidden dimensions
so that the features of the tokens are
also mixed among each other and until
here the transformation that was done
is reversible by the inverse fourier
transform in other words the components
of the cake
can be recovered by decomposing after
each frequency it is
the next step the feed forward layers
that mix
things even more and usually not in
an invertible way the second important
message
is that the mixing scheme or pattern is
not learned it is fixed and always
follows the same rule
making the architecture simpler and
easier to compute
it decreases the number of the learnable
parameters of the transformer
which now is technically ethnic and not
the transformer
thirdly a more advanced taco message
also
mentioned in the paper which miss coffee
bean found super interesting is the
following
you maybe know or if not just take miss
coffee beans word for it
convolutions in the real slash time
domain
corresponds to simple multiplications in
the fourier slash frequency domain so
the first fourier layer of the
architecture
moves the representation from the real
domain to the fourier domain
and multiplications in these layers
happening afterwards are now actually
convolutions
in the real space so by adding more and
more transformer layers
each one with one fourier layer fnet is
jumping back and forth from
multiplications to convolutions in other
words convolutions are
somehow here and perhaps now are taking
revenge on the transformer and crash
their party are convolutions all you
need i
actually cannot hear all you need
anymore but
miss coffee bean makes me say it okay
but one question remains
why exactly the fourier transform
reading the paper it becomes clear that
the first thing the authors tried was
simple linear mixing schemes but then
went with something more structured like
the fourier transform
but believe it or not the other paper
getting rid of attention
the mlp mixer learns mixing patterns
that look
very much like fourier just look here is
the base frequency
here is a double of that frequency with
its negative counterpart
the mlp mixer found something like a
fourier scheme on itself
but on images fnet has been applied to
text and has the fully transformation
hard coded and it seems to work also
well
so the f net basically is a bird variant
without
attention but fourier transformations
and achieves 92 percent of the accuracy
of bird on glue
an important nlu benchmark which is not
exactly 100
of bird but good enough and especially
because there is
no quadratically scaling attention
anymore it runs
seven times faster on gpu and two times
faster on tpus
and you can increase the sequence length
so self-attention was praised as being
the recipe to success for quite a while
but
now papers like fnet mlp mixer and gmlp
relativize this by a bit showing that if
there is enough
data and compute the architecture does
not matter much so
it seems like back in the days when mlps
were a thing
we discarded mlps too early when perhaps
the only thing that was missing
then was the data and compute scale we
have now
so we preferred cnns or rnns because of
their inductive biases
always a good idea with little data but
to say
this is very unfair because
architectures like fnet or mlp mixer are
not exactly like a vanilla mlp from back
then
the structure of these mlps follows the
trendset by transformers so miss
coffeebean sees
this as an evolution and not really as a
backwards involution or something in any
case
now that we have seen that long
sequences are not such of a problem
anymore
and that image token mixing and text
token mixing
looks quite similar miss coffee bean
thinks it's great news for
multi-modality where the goal is to
combine
many types of input data that
potentially comes
in very long sequences especially if you
append
one modality to another like vision and
language transformers do
the eff net paper is very well written
so what are you waiting for
leave a like subscribe share miss coffee
bean to center around the world
and go read the paper yourself okay bye
miss coffee bean it has been a while
since your last video
are you getting lazy or what oh
yes i know i put you in the coffee
roaster and left you there
but i was busy with moving and with a
paper
no no i did not waste my time
no miss coffee bean that's rude to say
go to your coffee roaster
okay